wir sind wieder ZDF heute live schön
dass ihr bei uns mit hier im Stream seid
und ihr seid genau richtig wir haben
hier für euch live Bilder aus Berlin aus
dem Wirtschaftsministerium vorliegenden
da wird Robert Habeck der
Wirtschaftsminister gleich vor die
Presse treten vor dem Mikrofone treten
und er wird die Ergebnisse des zweiten
Stresstests rund um die noch in
betrieblich befindlichen Atomkraftwerke
hier in Deutschland geben er wird
Antworten präsentieren was dabei
herausgekommen ist es ist natürlich ein
heikler Auftritt für Robert Habeck von
den Grünen und es ist auch eine
Kontroverse Frage um die UNO wir uns
heute kümmern was tun um im Winter in
Deutschland nicht den Blackout zu
erleben AKW Laufzeiten tatsächlich
verlängern oder bleibt es bei dem
Atomausstieg der gesellschaftlich und
auch politisch ja eigentlich schon für
Ende des Jahres besiegelt schien
Fragen von euch wie immer gerne in den
Chat direkt oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de so und wir sprechen
direkt mit unserer ZDF
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Nicole
Diekmann über das was da gleich
passieren wird mit Robert Habeck und um
den Stresstest Nicole wir müssen dich
glaube ich auch gleich sehen nein
Korrektur Robert Habeck hat schon Platz
genommen wir gehen direkt in die PK und
hören was der Wirtschaftsminister zu
sagen hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sehr geehrte Herren hier auf dem Podium
herzlich willkommen in der
Bundespressekonferenz
mit Blick auf die Zeit würde ich auf die
foto-kollegen bitten hier vorne die rein
etwas zu lichten dass alle etwas sehen
vielen Dank
ich begrüße sie alle zu dieser späten
Stunde für die
Bundespressekonferenz zumindest für uns
zur Verhältnisse und ich gehe mal davon
aus dass das was wir heute vorgestellt
bekommen inhaltlich die späte Stunde weg
macht es werden nämlich vorgestellt die
Ergebnisse des Stresstests die zweite
sonderanalyse
für den Winter 2022 2023
sehnlichst erwartet ich möchte Ihnen
dazu unsere Gäste vorstellen
bundeswirtschafts- und
klimaschutzminister Robert Habeck zu
meiner Rechten von ihnen aus gesehen
links Staatssekretär im bmwk Patrick
reichen und dann die Vertreter der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber Herr Stefan
Kraftverlauf von 50 Hertz Herr Dr
Neumann von ampion Herr Meier Jürgens
von Tennet und Herr Dr Götz von Transnet
Bw
herzlich Willkommen an sie alle schön
dass Sie unsere Gäste sind wir begrenzen
diese Pressekonferenz mit ein wenig
zeitlichen Puffer auf roundabout eine
Stunde es geht die altbewährte Regel
eine Frage eine Nachfrage pro Person und
wenn die Zeit es zulässt dann nehme ich
sie gerne wieder auf die Liste wenn es
weiteren Frage der Bedarf
gibt so viel davor Rede und ich übergebe
an sie habe
vielen Dank ich leite nur kurz ein bevor
die Kollegen von den
Übertragungsnetzbetreibern das Wort
bekommen um die den richtigen haben oder
den Rahmen zu setzen einmal möchte ich
vor die Klammer ziehen dass die
Versorgung Sicherheit in Deutschland
hoch ist wir haben eine hohe
Versorgungssicherheit wir sind ein
stromexportland wir haben eine große
Netzstabilität wir haben genug Energie
in Deutschland und versorgen unser
europäischen Nachbarn mit dieser Energie
mit
natürlich sind wir Teil eines
europäischen Energiesystems das heißt
das was in den europäischen
Nachbarländern passiert oder eben nicht
passiert beeinflusst auch den deutschen
Energiemarkt
dieses europäische Energiesystem und
dieses besondere Jahr führen dazu dass
jetzt zum dritten Mal die
Versorgungssicherheit intensiv geprüft
wurde eigentlich ein routinevorgang der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber in diesem Jahr
ist aber nichts Routine ein Jahr das
geprägt wurde durch die
Ausfälle oder energiepolitisch geprägt
wurde durch die Ausfälle von russischem
Gas und ihrem Ersatz von dem nicht am
Netz sein der französischen
Atomkraftwerke in einem großen und
stetigen Ausmaß dann dient das
Niedrigwasser im Rhein das früh im Jahr
kam und tiefer ging als das Jahr 2018
das bisher das trockenste oder das Jahr
mit den niedrigsten Pegelständen war was
insofern eine Relevanz für die
Energieversorgung hat als die
kohleschiffe die ja die
Steinkohlekraftwerke erreichen müssen
teilweise nicht mehr voll beladen werden
können
die Wasserkraft in Norwegen bis zu den
Alpen hat ebenfalls in dem Sommer
gelitten dazu kommt dass wir in den
letzten Jahren ich habe hier vor ein
paar Monaten gesessen und die Folien
hoch gehalten beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und beim Stromnetz
Ausbau geschürt haben und schlecht waren
wir heißt Deutschland insgesamt aber das
hat natürlich in bestimmten Regionen zu
besonderen engpasssituationen geführt
der Stresstest wurde von uns am 17 Juli
an die Übertragungsnetzbetreiber mit
Parametern übermittelt wie gleich zu
hören sein wird sind die Parameter durch
die Wirklichkeit des Jahres selbst schon
während der Berechnung übertroffen
worden sind wir am 17 Juli noch von dem
trockensten bisher und
katastrophalsten ja ausgegangen 2018
waren die Pegelstände im Rhein während
der Berechnung unter den Pegelständen
von 2018 und die tiefsten Pegelstände
wurden erst im Oktober gemessen
wir haben immer gedacht 300 Euro pro
Megawattstunde Gas ist ein extrem
Szenario während der letzten Wochen
wurde der Preis über 300 Euro noch
erreicht und wir hatten zwischendurch
Spitzen von 350 Euro die Trockenheit hat
nicht nur Südeuropa sondern auch
Nordeuropa in ihrem in ihre in ihre
Krallen bekommen entsprechend die
Situation an den Kohlekraftwerken so
dass wir oder die
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber während der
Arbeit gesagt haben wir müssen diese
Szenarien Nachschärfen und das wurde
auch getan sie werden gleich vier
Szenarien vorgestellt bekommen die nach
oben skaliert immer extremere Annahmen
machen und die Auswirkungen auf das
deutsche Energiesystem zwei letzte
darstellen zwei letzte Bemerkung oder
Anmerkungen erstens es ist ein
Stresstest das heißt er geht immer vom
Worst Case Szenario aus
entlang der Annahmen ich werde darauf
nachher noch einmal bei einer
politischen Einordnung und dem
politischen Konsequenzen zu sprechen
kommen und zweitens diese Szenarien sind
immer Ausschnitte zwischen den Szenarien
ist natürlich eine breite eine breite
Skala von anderen möglichen Szenarien
das ist ja eine Projektion der
Wirklichkeit aber die Wirklichkeit
entwickelt sich natürlich zwischen
diesen Szenarien dennoch gibt der
Stresstest mit denen vor
durchgerechneten Szenarien und ein sehr
gutes Bild über das was politisch
notwendig oder nicht nötig ist dazu dann
nach den Vorträgen mehr
vielen Dank bis hierhin dann machen wir
weiter bei den Herren der
übertragungsnetzbetreibe ich beginne bei
Herrn Dr Götz bitte sagen herzlichen
Dank meine Damen und Herren
mein Name ist Werner Götz ich vertrete
die Transnet BW ich würde Ihnen ganz
kurz die Beauftragung und die von uns
durchgeführte Berechnungsmethode
vorstellen wollen Herr Habeck hat
eingeführt dass wir
im Juli beauftragt wurden und sehr
kritische Prämissen anzugucken und damit
die
Kernfragen was erwarten wir in Bezug auf
die Stromnachfrage also ist die
Leistungsbilanz gedeckt und die Frage
ist die Netzsicherheit und die
Netzstabilität gewährleistet
in simulationsrechnen Rechnungen
bewertet haben
zur durchgeführten Methodik die erste
zentrale Zielsetzung für uns war die
Klärung der Frage ob unter den gewählten
Prämissen die elektrische Energie
national in Deutschland und europaweit
jederzeit gedeckt werden kann wir
bezeichnen das als
Leistungsbilanz
Betrachtung das heißt konkret wir
ermitteln für jede Stunde des Jahres
also für alle 8.760 Stunden die konkrete
Frage ist der Bedarf den wir national in
Deutschland den wir Europa in Europa
sehen gedeckt durch den gegebenen
Kraftwerkspark auf Basis der
aktuellen erzeugungssituation heißt es
auch wir haben eine Wetterabhängigkeit
zu bewerten wir haben das exemplarisch
durchgeführt für das Jahr 2012 das heißt
das Wetterjahr das historische
Wetterjahr 2012 ist hier als
Eingangsparameter unterstellt worden
warum 2012 aber im Jahr 2012 der ein
oder andere wird sich erinnern
sehr kalten
ich würde fast sagen extrem kalten
Winter hatten so dass wir hier um hier
auch wirklich in den Prämissen unsere
Fragestellung hart zu treffen ein
extremwerter Jahr unterstellt haben
durchgerechnet wurde dann wie gesagt
jede einzelne Stunde wir haben ermittelt
inwieweit auf Basis einer europaweiten
marktbetrachtung Angebot und
Nachfrage jederzeit gedeckt werden kann
die zweite zentrale Fragestellung die
wir bewertet haben war ist die Energie
die wir erzeugen auch über unser
bestehendes Transportnetz transportabel
dorthin wo die Energie gebraucht wird
das ist eine Fragestellung die sich mit
der Netzsicherheit in einem
engpassfreien sicheren netzzustand
beschäftigt
vor diesem Hintergrund sind ermittelt
worden notwendige netzeingriffe die den
markteinsatz einschränken also unter dem
Schlagwort re dispatch inwieweit sind
redes Patch Bedarfe gegeben zu welchen
Stunden sind kritischen netzsituationen
erwartbar und wie werden die Maßnahmen
die da notwendig werden um diese
kritischen netzsituationen zu
beherrschen
wir haben hier zwei kritische
netzsituationen bewertet das eine ist im
Prinzip die was wir als
ja hohe erzeugungssituation sehen also
hohe Nachfrage hohe Erzeugung und das
andere ist das was wie in der
Allgemeinheit als
dunkelflaute betrachten beide Fälle sind
von uns bewertet worden ich würde zu der
Erläuterung der Prämissen an meinen
Kollegen Tim majugens von der Tennet
übergeben
gut dann auch von meiner Seite schön
guten Abend mein Name ist Timba Jungs
vertrete die Tennet hier
und darf ihn heute noch mal die
Szenarien vorstellen die wir zugrunde
gelegt haben bevor ich auf die Szenarien
komme noch einmal ein kleiner Exkurs zum
Release Patch dann das Wort ist auf der
aller Munde doch ist nicht immer jedem
klar was wir darunter verstehen
also zur Ausgangssituation noch mal wir
haben ja in Deutschland eine
Elektrizitätsnetz das Engpässe aufweist
da wir gerade in Norden und Nordosten
Deutschlands sehr viel Erzeugung haben
während wir im Süden und Südwesten eher
hohe Last vorfinden
ja und dazwischen muss das Netz eben
übertragungsleistungen vollbringen und
ist nicht überall ausreichend ausgebaut
bisher
das man kann also kurz zusammenpassen
wir haben im Nordosten relativ viel
leistungserzeugung wir holen gegen wir
im Südwesten zu wenig haben und das
führt dann teilweise zu
leitungsüberlastung den wir
entgegenwirken müssen außerdem aufgrund
der zentralen Lage Deutschland in Europa
sind wir auch für den Transit natürlich
eine zentrale Drehscheibe für die
leistungsflüsse aus den nordischen
Ländern Richtung Südeuropa und auch im
ost-transport
die Behebung dieser Engpässe das machen
wir durch den sogenannten redest Patch
wir unterscheiden dort in sogenannten
negativen redest Patch und positiven
redestpatch das heißt der negative redes
page bedeutet dass wir Leistung im
Nordosten absenken und im gleichen Maße
dann im Südwestdeutschland vorhandene
Kraftwerke hochfahren mit positiven
reeduspatch und dadurch dass wir die
Energiebilanz ausgleichen können wir
dann die Leitungen entlasten und stellen
Sohn den sicheren Netzbetrieb sicher
wenn wir zu den Grundlagen für die
Analyse kommen wir haben ja eine
Bedarfsanalyse
22 gemacht die finden Sie auch noch mal
in dem Ausdruck auf Seite 6 und wir
hatten die Herr Minister Harbeck das
angekündigt hatte dann im Frühjahr eine
sonderanalyse gemacht weil wir eben
aufgrund der Situation in der Ukraine
gesehen haben dass wir eine angespannte
Netzsituation haben und haben dann
gerechnet was es bedeutet
dazu kam in diesem Jahr viele weitere
Einflüsse auf unser Netz
einige davon sind angesprochen worden
wir sehen eine extreme Trockenheit in
ganz Europa wir sehen das in Frankreich
ein Großteil der
kernkraftwerksflotte nicht zur Verfügung
steht und das hat dazu geführt dass wir
eben in dieser Analyse noch mal drei
weitere Szenarien betrachten
drei Szenarien die hier als Plus
doppelplus und dreifach plus
gekennzeichnet sind indem wir
die Verfügbarkeit der Kern Laufwerke in
Frankreich von ursprünglich 61 GW auf 45
bzw im dritten Szenario 40 GW absenken
in der wir berücksichtigen dass wir
einige Kraftwerke jetzt aus der
netzreserve zurückführen in den Markt
also Kohlekraftwerke die den Markt damit
wieder zur Verfügung stehen aber auch
nicht immer voll verfügbar sind
wir haben berücksichtigt die besondere
Situation des Kohle Transports auf den
Flüssen und auch dass die Verfügbarkeit
von Kühlwasser die haben wir in den
verschiedenen Szenarien mit meinem
Abstand von zwei drei bzw 3,75 GW
berücksichtigt
auch die Verfügbarkeit der netzreserve
haben wir in den einzelnen Serien weiter
reduziert
genauso wie die Verfügbarkeit von Gas
für den Einsatz in Gaskraftwerken vor
allem in Süddeutschland und Österreich
wir sind also von
ursprünglich 100% in den Szenarien 2+
und 3+ auf 75 bzw 50% runtergegangen in
der gasverfügbarkeit was wir auch
berücksichtigt haben ist aufgrund des
gasmangels das eventuell eine höhere
elektrische Last Auftritt in dem eben
elektrisch geheizt wird zum Beispiel
durch Heizlüfter das haben wir mit 1,5
GW bzw im dritten Szenario mit 2,5 GB
berücksichtigt und auch schon wie
angesprochen die höheren Gaspreise die
dann Auswirkungen natürlich auch auf den
Einsatz der Gaskraftwerke haben
das ist letztendlich die Grundlage
gewesen
verschieden starke Stress für das Netz
von einem Szenario das ja aufgrund der
besonderen Gegebenheiten die wir heute
haben sicherlich
ein Stress für das Netz ist aber auch
nicht völlig aus der Welt bis hin zu dem
3+ Szenario wo wir wirklich alles noch
mal überlagert haben was wir uns im
Moment denken können und was schon wie
ich jetzt was gestern nach Rio ist und
auf Basis dieser Szenarien haben wir
dann eben das Netz untersucht einmal
hinsichtlich der Leistungsbilanz wie
Herr Dr Götz das ausgeführt hat und im
zweiten hinsichtlich des redes Batch und
der Netzsicherheit und damit würde ich
dann an meinen Kollegen
ja guten Abend auch von meiner Seite
Hendrik Neumann technischer
Geschäftsführer der ambrion und ich
möchte mit Ihnen im Folgenden einmal die
wesentlichen Ergebnisse dieser
sonderanalyse durchgehend das ist in
ihren Folien auf der Seite 7 im Handout
und zwar haben wir zwei
untersuchungsschwerpunkte gehabt zum
einen die Untersuchung der
Stromnachfrage und zum anderen ja die
Frage der Netzsicherheit insgesamt sind
das exakt vier Szenarien die wir uns
angeschaut haben also einmal das
Szenario plus bis zum Szenario dreifach
Plus und dann die zusätzliche
Sensitivität
hinsichtlich der Kernkraftwerke im
streckbetrieb
ja wenn wir uns die Ergebnisse anschauen
dann wird deutlich und das
erwartungsgemäß dass hier eine ganz
unterschiedliche Kritikalität vorliegt
man kann allerdings zusammenfassend
sagen dass sich die Versorgungssituation
in allen drei Szenarien doch als äußerst
angespannt darstellt wir sehen das in
der Grafik das bezogen auf das
europäische Marktgebiet in allen drei
szenarienstunden auftreten in denen die
Last nicht gedeckt ist
und zwar erstreckt sich hier die
Spannbreite von 14 Stunden mit bis zu 7
Gigawatt also 7000 Megawatt im Szenario
einfach plus bis zu 91 Stunden mit 19
Gigawatt im Szenario dreifach plus
vielleicht ganz kurz zu Einordnung so
über den Daumen gerechnet 7000 MW das
entspricht ungefähr der Versorgung von 7
Millionen Menschen
in Deutschland sehen wir ab dem Szenario
zweifach plus ebenfalls Stunden mit
lastunterdeckung
in diesem Szenario doppelplus in der
Größenordnung von ca 1 bis 2 Stunden mit
bis zu
700 Megawatt auch da vielleicht noch mal
um ein bisschen
Fingerspitzengefühl dafür zu bekommen
was bedeuten 700 MB es entspricht
ungefähr dem Verbrauch der Großstadt
Frankfurt im Szenario dreifach Plus ist
die Versorgungssituation erwartungsgemäß
besonders kritisch dort sehen wir bis zu
zwölf Stunden
lastunterdeckung mit bis zu 8000
Megawatt
ja was bedeutet das konkret das würde
ich Ihnen gerne auch noch mal kurz
erläutern das bedeutet sollte eine
solche Situation eintreten so greifen
hierfür die von den
Übertragungsnetzbetreibern vorbereiteten
Prozesse einmal der deutschen ÜNB aber
natürlich die Prozesse in Zusammenarbeit
mit unseren europäischen Partnern und
das beinhaltet auch dass national sowie
international alle verfügbaren Reserven
eingesetzt werden sollte das nicht
reichen um die Systemsicherheit zu
gewährleisten erfolgt dann ein Prozess
in dem das geordnete Abschalten von
Verbrauchern für ein begrenzten Zeitraum
dazu dient dass die Sicherheit des
Gesamtsystems weiterhin gewährleistet
bleibt
bei der Untersuchung zur Netzsicherheit
also dem Untersuchungsschwerpunkt 2
haben wir berechnet wie hoch der
Eingriff der ÜNB notwendigerweise ist um
die Erzeugung in die Erzeugung um die
Netzsicherheit in Deutschland zu
gewährleisten das ist genau das was der
Kollege meyer-jürgens erklärt hat was
wir mit ridispatch bezeichnen besonders
kritisch ist hierbei die Verfügbarkeit
von Kraftwerken zu Erhöhung der Leistung
im Süden und im südwestlichen Teil
unseres Netzes
über die drei Szenarien das sehen Sie
auf der Folie 8 zeigt sich das mit
Verschärfung der Annahmen auch die
Intensität der notwendigen Eingriffe der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber also der
redestpatch Bedarf steigt
eine weitere wesentliche Erkenntnis ist
das in keinem dieser 30 Szenarien das in
Deutschland verfügbare dispatch
Potenzial ausreicht und die
Netzsicherheit zu gewährleisten und das
bedeutet in der Konsequenz dass
zusätzlich zu der in Deutschland
verfügbaren netzreserve und der bereits
in Österreich oder mit Österreich
kontrahierten Leistung weitere
redespätschleistung im Ausland in doch
erheblicher Höhe notwendig ist um die
Netzsicherheit weiter zu gewährleisten
und die Analysen zeigen dass wir hierzu
eine Spannbreite von 4,3 Gigawatt
bis zu 8,6 Gigawatt im Szenario dreifach
plus benötigen
lassen Sie mich an der Stelle noch
einmal anmerken ob diese Leistung dann
tatsächlich zur Verfügung steht ist
aufgrund der in ganz Europa angespannten
Versorgungslage unsicher schließlich
kämpfen alle unsere Nachbarländer mit
sehr ähnlichen Herausforderungen
dann würde ich gerne das auf der Folie 9
einmal darauf eingehen was die
Auswirkung der drei Kernkraftwerke im
streckbetrieb bedeutet und sowohl für
die Versorgungssituation als auch dann
im weiteren für die Netzsicherheit wir
hatten hierzu mit dem bmwk vereinbart
dass wir diese Sensitivität im Szenario
zweifach plus also in den mittleren
Szenario ermitteln und dabei zunächst
der Blick auf die Versorgungssituation
das ist ja letztlich genau die Frage ob
zu jedem Zeitpunkt ausreichend
Stromerzeugung vorhanden ist um die
Nachfrage aus den Stromverbrauch zu
decken
hier zeigen die Analysen dass alle drei
Kernkraftwerke einen Beitrag zur
Reduzierung der lastunterdeckung in
Europa und in Deutschland leisten in
Deutschland führt dies dazu dass
lastunterdeckung weitestgehend vermieden
werden können
dann noch einmal der Blick auf die
Netzsicherheit also den zweiten
Untersuchungsschwerpunkt im
sensitivitätsszenario mit den drei
Kernkraftwerken im streckbetrieb da
zeigt sich dass der Netz dass die da
zeigt die netzsicherheitsanalyse mit den
drei Kernkraftwerken steckbetrieb dass
wir zu einem geringeren redest Patch
Bedarf insgesamt kommen das heißt das
Netz ist weniger stark und auch weniger
häufig überlastet es bleibt allerdings
insgesamt auf einem weiterhin hohen und
kritischen auslastungsniveau
die im Ausland zusätzlich vorzuhaltende
Leistung für redespatch sinkt durch die
drei Kernkraftwerke im streckbetrieb um
ca 0,5 Gigawatt bleibt aber weiterhin
hoch
was die Analysen auch zeigen ist dass
wir weniger häufig und weniger stark auf
den nicht sicher im Ausland verfügbaren
redestage zurückgreifen müssen dieser
Sicherheitsgewinn ist in einigen Stunden
noch deutlich höher als die in der
kritischen Stunde in der
dimensionierungsrelevanten kritischen
Stunde mit 0,5 GW ermittelt worden das
so haben die Analysen gezeigt dass wir
in einigen Stunden
teilweise über einem Gigawatt weniger
redes Patch aus dem Ausland benötigen
damit übergebe ich an den Kollegen
ja vielen Dank Hendrik Stefan Kapferer
Vorsitzender Geschäftsführung von 50
Hertz auf Seite 11 da sind wir
inzwischen angekommen finden sie noch
mal zusammengefasst in kurzen
Botschaften das was der Kollege Neumann
gerade eben vorgetragen hat also noch
mal zusammengefasst die Frage
hinsichtlicher Leistungsbilanz die in
dem zweitkritischsten und in dem
kritischsten Szenario auch in
Deutschland nicht in allen Stunden
ausreichend gedeckt ist und insbesondere
hinsichtlich der Netzsicherheit wie er
nochmal gerade eben ausgeführt hat wo
wir in allen Szenarien eine erheblichen
videospatch Bedarf sehen und sie sehen
auch noch mal dort aufgeführt wie im
mittleren also im zweitkritischen
Szenario die Nutzung der drei
Kernkraftwerke sich auswirken würde
hinsichtlich der lastabdeckung und der
Netzsicherheit wir haben zusätzlich auch
noch berechnet wie ist die Auswirkung
auf den Gasverbrauch und sie finden auch
diese Zahl dort nämlich 0,9 TB
weniger Gas würde in Deutschland
verstromt werden 1,5 TB weniger im
europäischen Ausland insgesamt glaube
ich ist klar geworden dass wir vor einer
angespannten Situation in ganz Europa im
Winter stehen und deswegen finden Sie
auf der Seite 12 die Vorschläge der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber um dieser
Situation vor allem natürlich in
Deutschland aber auch im Energie
Binnenmarkt gerecht zu werden und unsere
Botschaft ist ganz klar es ist sinnvoll
und notwendig alle Möglichkeiten zur
Erhöhung der
Stromerzeugung und der
Transportkapazitäten zu
das erstere Stromerzeugung je nach
Standort der Erzeugungskapazitäten dient
zum einen natürlich den medispatch
Bedarf im Süden der ja sehr hoch ist wie
wir geschildert haben und dient
natürlich insgesamt zur lastabdeckung
die Erhöhung der Transportkapazitäten
dient natürlich vorrangig der
Notwendigkeit den redest Bad Bedarf zu
senken deswegen ist auch der erste
Vorschlag die Transportkapazität
innerhalb Deutschlands zu erhöhen das
ist möglich mit
witterungsabhängig im
freileitungsbetrieb sie wissen dass je
nach Temperatur Netz unterschiedlich
ausgelastet werden können dazu ist es
notwendig ein erheblichen datenbedarf
auch zu haben und entsprechende
gesetzliche Regelungen können dabei auch
helfen und wir schlagen vor dass hier
die Bundesregierung tätig wird um die
nord-süd-transportkapazität zu erhöhen
zweitens wir brauchen klare und
verbindliche Absprachen über das
wedispatch Potenzial im Ausland es ist
jetzt wiederholt gesagt worden dass wir
derzeit als übergangsnetzbetreiber
versuchen weitere 6,6 Gigawatt zu
kontrahieren aber das kein Selbstläufer
die Situation in den Nachbarländern ist
angespannt deswegen müssen wir natürlich
hier auch gucken dass wir mit den
Nachbarländern in ein intensiven
Austausch gehen und verbindliche
Absprachen treffen drittens wir schlagen
vor vertragliches Lastmanagement möglich
zu machen was heißt das der ein oder
andere wird sie erinnern dass wir bis
mitte diesen Jahres die sogenannte
Ablauf hatten die
Möglichkeit die Verordnung zur
Abschaltung von Lasten da werden
Industrie oder wurden Industriebetriebe
vergütet wenn sie für Stunden Last vom
Netz genommen haben um System dienlich
dann das Netz nutzen zu können das ist
ausgelaufen im Juni wir sagen nicht man
muss dieselbe Regelung wieder einführen
aber es ist sicherlich sinnvoll für den
bevorstehenden Winter darüber
nachzudenken gibt es große Lasten die
bereit sind gegen eine entsprechende
Entschädigung dann aus dem System zu
nehmen wenn es dem System nutzt und wir
dafür dann lastunterdeckung vermeiden
können oder möglicherweise im Süden dann
auch das Bett Potential absenken können
viertens alle Reserven die netzreserve
aber auch die netztechnischen
Betriebsmittel sollen natürlich für alle
Notwendigkeiten im Strommarkt zur
Verfügung stehen ich glaube das sind
wichtiger Punkt und schließlich der
fünfte Punkt wir müssen natürlich die
Nutzung aller Erzeugungskapazitäten in
diesen Stresssituationen absichern die
Kollegen haben darauf hingewiesen dass
wir ja in den Stresssituationen
gerechnet haben wann stehen wie viel
Kohlekraftwerke zur Verfügung das sind
nicht ganz entscheidend ist die
Kohleversorgung gesichert durch die
entsprechenden Transportkapazitäten sind
die entsprechenden Genehmigungen
wasserrechtlich emissionsrechtlich
erteilt das muss alles jetzt zügig
gelöst werden wir brauchen natürlich
auch die Situation dass insbesondere
dort wo die Gaskraftwerke für ready
speech im Süden benötigt werden auch
dort gewährleistet ist dass das
funktioniert und schließlich unter 5c
großer Hinweis dass natürlich auch ein
Baustein wäre aus unserer Sicht die
Verfügbarkeit der Kernkraftwerke um bei
kritischen Situationen die
Beherrschbarkeit der Situation des
Systems zu steigern all das sind
hoheitliche Fragestellungen oder
gesetzgeberische freistellen darüber
sind wir bereits im Austausch mit dem
Ministerium es ist eben gesagt worden
wenn das alles nicht reicht dann haben
wir natürlich immer noch Möglichkeiten
nämlich entweder den Export ins Ausland
dann entsprechend anders zu steuern oder
dann auch regional Last aus dem System
zu nehmen das wäre dann nicht mehr auf
der Grundlage einer freiwilligen
Vereinbarung auf der letzten Seite
finden Sie noch eine kleine Übersicht
was bringen die einzelnen Maßnahmen die
wir gerade vorgestellt haben ich glaube
ich will das jetzt nicht im Einzelnen
vorstellen um die Zeit auch nicht zu
sprengen aber Sie sehen dass doch
erhebliche Kapazitäten grundsätzlich zur
Verfügung stehen sowohl beim
Lastmanagement als auch in den einzelnen
Reserven aber das natürlich bitte auch
sie berücksichtigen das kann man nicht
alles aufeinander stapeln und dann kommt
raus dass wir eigentlich gar kein
Problem haben sondern es zeigt es gibt
verschiedene Möglichkeiten manche sind
natürlich nur zur lastigungen geeignet
manche sind dann für die Netzsicherheit
geeignet das gibt noch mal einen kleinen
Überblick welche Möglichkeiten zur
Verfügung stehen aber wie gesagt wir
glauben dass ein Set von Möglichkeiten
notwendig ist um den kommenden Winter
dann auch sicher zu beherrschen
vielen Dank dass hier hin ich komme zu
ihren Fragen wie zahlreich angemeldet
wurden
machen wir das ich glaube sie sinnvoll
wenn ich kurz erläutere was wir
Regierung seitlich daraus für
Konsequenzen ziehen
fünf Minuten erbittet der Minister ich
würde sagen also dann vielen Dank
lassen Sie mich ganz kurz die Debatte
einordnen wenn ich darf es ist eine
Debatte die in Deutschland traditionell
hohe politische wellenschlägt die viele
Emotionen bindet und auch natürlich die
Republik lange beschäftigt hat und jetzt
wieder dabei ist die Republik zu
beschäftigen alle Parteien haben ihre
Haltung dazu einige haben ihre Haltung
dazu korrigiert andere haben das nicht
getan und einige korrigieren ihre
Haltung kann man
meine Aufgabe ist es in dieser Situation
mich davon freizumachen
wir müssen als Regierung und ich als
verantwortlicher Minister für die
versorgungshalt Sicherheit in
Deutschland die richtige Entscheidung
treffen und ich werde alles dafür notive
tun diese Versorgungssicherheit zu
gewährleisten
Atomkraft ist eine hochrisikotechnologie
und alles Nötige tun heißt das unnötige
eben auch zu unterlassen weil es eine
hochrisikotechnologie ist wieder
Gesetzgeber mehrfach jetzt entschieden
hat und wie hoch richterliche auch
geurteilt wurde in Deutschland deswegen
müssen wir uns konkret die Szenarien
anschauen und die richtigen Schlüsse
daraus ableiten
und für mich wenn ich das so sagen darf
haben diese Studien durchaus
überraschende Ergebnisse die ohne diese
Studien so nicht zu erwarten gewesen
wären wenn ich kurz beginnen darf die
Debatte begann ja im März mit der Frage
kann der Weiterbetrieb der
Atomkraftwerke eine signifikante Menge
an Gas einsparen und wir sehen jetzt in
dieser Studie dass der einsparanteil von
Deutschland noch geringer ist als
erwartet unter ein Promille liegt für
das europäische Ausland ist der höher
was man leicht erklären kann die
Gaskraftwerke die im Moment laufen
produzieren im Wesentlichen Strom für
das europäische Ausland aber für
Deutschland ist der einsparanteil
so gering dass wie am Anfang der Debatte
schon festgestellt dass die Abwägung
eine hochrisikotechnologie für eine
geringe Menge
0,9% des
Gasverbrauchs in Deutschland zu
reduzieren meine Ansicht nach nicht
verhältnismäßig werden
0,09 die
[Musik]
zweite Erkenntnis ist das unter dass ich
das deutsche Stromsystem als sehr robust
erweist und dass wir genug
Stromkapazitäten in Deutschland haben um
die Versorgungssicherheit und die
Netzstabilität
festzustellensicherheit zu garantieren
und die Netzsicherheit ebenfalls
auszufüllen deswegen haben auch die
basis-studien der über eine
ertragungsnetzbetreiber das immer wieder
bestätigt unter Annahme der Probleme die
im Wesentlichen durch Ausfall auch der
europäischen Kraftwerke und der
redesfälschkapazitäten im europäischen
Ausland entstehen gibt es unter
bestimmten Szenarien sehr kalter Winter
große Ausfälle von Atomstrom in
Frankreich beispielsweise
stundenhafte
Mangelsituation die sie noch einmal für
Deutschland bezogen auf der Seite ich
glaube die Seite 9 dort finden
bei dem plus plus Szenario das Jahr
schon davon ausgeht dass wir erhebliche
Mengen nicht zur Verfügung haben wie
eben ausgeführt beträgt der Anteil der
versorgungsliste der der der
fehlenden stromlänge 0,7 bis eine
gigawattstunde bei ein bis zwei Stunden
pro Tag und dann in dem nächsten
Szenario 12 Stunden von 7 bis 8 GB das
ist dann wiederum erheblich
der Anteil der Atomkraftwerke ist also
messbar aber er speist sich aus einer
Situation die maßgeblich dadurch
hergestellt wird was im europäischen
Ausland insgesamt diese Engpässe sind
und die dritte Überraschung ist eine
doppelte wie wenn ich das so sagen darf
oder Erkenntnis Überraschung ist
vielleicht das falsche Wort ist eine
doppelte bei der Netzstabilität beim
sogenannten redes Patch wie Herr Meier
Jürgens ausgeführt hat gibt es dann doch
eine große Lücke und wenn ich das sagen
darf eine erstaunlich große Lücke und in
der großen Lücke hat die Atomkraft ein
relativ geringen Anteil diese Lücke zu
schließen die Lücke beträgt in den
Szenarien zwischen vier Gigawatt und 8
Gigawatt mit ein paar Kommazahlen
hinterher die Atomkraft verringert sie
um 0,5 GB was heißt das politisch
wir brauchen ein Set von Maßnahmen und
das ist ja auch die Empfehlung die über
die Empfehlung der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber nicht die eine
Maßnahme hilft und schon gar nicht beim
redes Patch also beim Schließen der
kapazitätslücke für die Netzstabilität
die erste Maßnahme ist eine die hier gar
nicht erwähnt wurde und das ist auch
richtig so denn es ist ja ein Stresstest
er soll also von extrem Annahmen
ausgehen ich will aber sagen dass es
eine gewisse blaue besilibität hat das
mit gesteigerten extremen der Preis für
den Strom natürlich steigt und in den
extremsszenarien ich würde sagen extrem
hoch ist das heißt wir werden im Markt
verbrauchsreduktionen sehen einfach
durch den hohen Preis alles andere wäre
unplausibel aber noch einmal wir können
es uns leisten und das auch wichtig
diese unplausibilität in die Studie mit
reinzustellen denn wer weiß schon ob es
nicht doch irgendwie anders kommt weil
Leute sich kontra intuitiv gegen die
ökonomischen Überlegungen dann doch
entscheiden die Stromverbräuche
hochzuhalten oder die Industrie trotzdem
weiter produziert aber mit einer
gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit sind die
Sensitivitäten im Markt größer und hier
nicht berücksichtigt was jedenfalls in
den mittleren Szenarien das Problem
verringern würde trotzdem
sind hier nicht in einer Situation wo
wir auf das Beste hoffen können sondern
wir müssen mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen
und deswegen braucht es weitere
Maßnahmen ein paar sind genannt maximale
Auslastung des Stromnetzes weitere
Kapazitäten ans Netz bringen Kohle haben
wir schon gesagt die Probleme im Reinen
sind beschrieben die Auslastung von
Biomassekraftwerken wird jetzt mit der
dritten n-signovelle vorgenommen werden
das Lastmanagement wieder einzuführen
das heißt also vor Verträge zu schließen
dass Kapazitäten abgeschlossen werden
all das ist richtig und auch vorgelagert
und notwendig denn das passiert ja jetzt
schon von Biomasse bis zu
Lastmanagement und dann kommen wir kurz
zur Frage der Atomkraftwerke
und man kann in der Situation nicht
ausschließen dass sie bei der
angespannten Situation einen Beitrag
leisten können die ganzen Studien gehen
davon aus dass es bestimmte
Voraussetzungen gibt und wir haben in
einem gewissen Sinne die schwierige Lage
dass wir Anfang September eine
Entscheidung treffen müssen die
vielleicht im Januar oder im Februar
ihre Konsequenzen nach sich zieht
deswegen ist die für mich richtige
Konsequenz aus dem Gesagten aus dem
Stresstest dass wir uns diese Option
erhalten nach dem Ende der regulären
Laufzeit der Atomkraftwerke die beiden
süddeutschen Atomkraftwerke in eine
Reserve überführen so dass sie
wieder genutzt werden können oder weiter
genutzt werden können wenn die Situation
ist gebietet und wir uns dieser Option
nicht entledigen
das ist eine Entscheidung der Abwägung
denn ich habe sagte schon es ist eine
hochrisikotechnologie die darauf den
Leistungsbetrieb Ende des Jahres beenden
sollte aber das ist eine sowohl
vertretbare wie notwendige Entscheidung
meine ich und so werde ich es der
Regierung bzw den koalitionsaktionen
vorschlagen wie ist das zu verstehen nun
der Stresstest der Schlaglichter auf
Szenarien liefert
kann auch rückwärts gelesen werden wir
wissen ja im Dezember und im Januar und
im Februar man kann das Skalieren
wie sich die Situation in Frankreich
entwickelt hat wir werden im Dezember
eine Ahnung haben wie sich die reinpegel
entwickelt haben ob es geregnet hat das
gleiche gilt für die Füllstände von
Wasserkraftwerken im Rhein oder in den
Alpen oder auch in Norwegen und wir
werden natürlich in den Jahreswechsel
auch eine ungefähre Ahnung haben wie
viel Gas Energie wir im November im
Dezember verbraucht haben so dass wir
dann in der Lage sind
auf die konkrete Situation die richtige
Entscheidung zu treffen lange Rede
kurzer Sinn nicht die eine Entscheidung
löst unser Problem sondern es ist ein
Set von verschiedenen Maßnahmen in
diesem Set kann der die Nutzung der
beiden süddeutschen Atomkraftwerke eine
Rolle haben vielleicht einen Unterschied
machen deswegen wäre es falsch sich
diese Option zu entledigen ob diese
Szenarien eintreten muss genau
beobachtet und monitor-werk gemonitored
werden und dann haben wir in der
Abwägung der verschiedenen Risiken die
wir zu treffen haben die Möglichkeit die
richtigen konkreten Entscheidungen dann
in der Situation zu treffen soweit
vielen Dank
vielen Dank bis hierhin ich komme zu
ihren Fragen und wir werden sehen wie
weit wir kommen es sind schon viele
angemeldet ich bin am Anfang bei der
Kollegin von ihnen aus gesehen links
mit dem violetten Blazer
verdienen sie sind als nächstes dran
kommt schon
es ist schon an ja
den noch nicht so richtig was das
bedeuten soll dass wenn man die AKW in
einen Notbetrieb versetzt also sie was
heißt das was ist der Unterschied zu
einem streckbetrieb können Sie das
vielleicht einmal erläutern und wie das
dann ganz konkret vollzogen werden kann
und welche
also was sie damit jetzt alles noch
machen müssen müssen sie das noch
absegnen lassen also wie es jetzt der
ganze organisatorische Lauf den das
ganze jetzt nehmen muss oder können Sie
das einfach so beschließen
der streitbetrieb hat sich so
eingebürgert in der sprachheilung ist
das weiterlaufen lassen der
Atomkraftwerke über das Ende der
laufzeitgenehmigung 31.12 diesen Jahres
hinaus mit den Kapazitäten die sie noch
haben die Brennelemente werden
abgebrannt nach Möglichkeiten das ist
der streckbetrieb das was wir
vorschlagen was ich vorschlage ist diese
Option zu ermöglichen aber nicht
automatisch jetzt zu beschließen aus
Grund der besonderen Technik Atomkraft
hochrisikotechnologie damit würden sie
überführt werden in einer Reserve wir
kennen es von den Kohlekraftwerken wobei
man die Techniken nicht vergleichen kann
sie werden einsatzbereit gehalten
Kühlkreisläufe werden nicht unterbrochen
Sicherheitschecks werden weiter
durchgeführt das Personal wird auch
gehalten aber sie produzieren kein Strom
mehr und für den Fall dass wir sie
brauchen fahren Sie wieder an und
produzieren dann Strom
das kann natürlich auch schon im
Dezember entschieden werden also wenn
wir im Dezember sehen dass dieses Jahr
sich weiter so extrem entwickelt hat und
dass die Zusagen und die Pläne
beispielsweise der französischen
Regierung und auch von EDF
Kapazitäten wieder ans Netz
zurückzubringen sich nicht bewahrheitet
haben dann können wir diese Entscheidung
natürlich auch schon vor Ende des Jahres
treffen und würden dann in den
sogenannten streckprinzip einschwenken
aber es kann sich eben auch anders
entwickeln und wenn ich das kurz sagen
darf Frankreich plant hat das mehrfach
bestätigt und in Schrift wie in
mündlicher Form immer wieder beteuert
zum Januar zum Jahreswechsel 50 Gigawatt
nukleare Kapazität am Netz zu haben im
Moment haben Sie gute 20 am Netz die
Szenarien mit denen wir gerechnet haben
oder die Übertragungsnetzbetreiber
gerechnet haben gehen nicht mehr von 50
aus sondern von 45 und dann 40 also 10
20 Prozent ab wir haben also da oder die
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber und wir schon
einen Abschlag gemacht aber die
Franzosen erzielen anderes und jetzt
können wir uns anschauen wie es sich in
der Wirklichkeit entwickelt werden die
technischen Probleme die
Sicherheitsprobleme gelöst oder nicht
und so entsprechend die europäischen
Nachbarn mit dem wir im stetigen Kontakt
sind alle sagen wir werden die
Kapazitäten vorhalten können
aber man kann es eben nicht sicher
annehmen nicht in diesem Jahr das heißt
wir warten uns für einen Fall der
passieren kann aber natürlich in dem
Planungen nicht vorgesehen ist
dann bin ich bei Frau Herzog
so ganz habe ich es noch nicht
verstanden also wenn die so ein bisschen
direkt ans Mikro sprechen
also für die
[Musik]
so wir sind jetzt etwas früher aus der
Pressekonferenz wir haben ihn hier
hinter uns noch Wirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck rausgegangen um so ein
bisschen auch Einordnung zu geben halten
wir ganz kurz fest nach dieser
Pressekonferenz die zwei der drei
verbliebenen Atomkraftwerke werden jetzt
vorübergehend in einen streckbetrieb
versetzt und dann auch in einen
reservezustand so wir ordnen das ein mit
Nicole Dieckmann sie hat gemeinsam mit
uns diese Pressekonferenz verfolgt ZDF
hauptstadtkorrespondentin schönen guten
Abend erstmal Nicole hi
hallo schönen guten Abend aus Berlin wie
bewertest du jetzt eben diese
Entscheidung also
Atomausstieg hat habe ich auch noch in
einer Pressemitteilung gesagt daran
halten wir fest aber wir machen jetzt
eben doch diesen streckbetrieb und eben
diesen reservezustand wie ordnest du das
ein
naja er hat es ja gerade
versucht klein zu reden dass Szenario
das ist tatsächlich passieren kann dass
diese beiden Atommeiler dann wieder voll
zum Einsatz kommen hat vorgerechnet auch
mit Hilfe von Experten die neben ihm
saßen in der Bundespressekonferenz warum
es und wahrscheinlich ist dass es
tatsächlich zu einer Lücke kommt dass
Blackouts drohen und
hat auch ein Wort das habe ich mir hier
aufgeschrieben mehrfach benutzt
hochrisikotechnologie es gehört zu DNA
der Grünen atomkraft nein danke
Atomkraft abzuschaffen
was Robert Habeck jetzt heute versucht
hat ist oder immer noch versucht ist
zum einen daran festzuhalten also die
Idee der Grünen nicht zu verraten und
gleichzeitig Realpolitik zu machen und
das ist jetzt der schmale grad auf dem
er wandelt
ja wie schwierig das ist hast du schon
gerade angesprochen für ihn ich glaube
das hat man auch so ein bisschen in der
Strategie gerade gesehen erst einmal nur
die Einleitung dann haben die Experten
gesprochen dann hinten raus ist er doch
noch mal zur kontextuierung gekommen
erst zum Schluss auch etwas konkret
geworden also da steckt sehr viel
Dilemma für ihn und für die Grünen auch
an sich drin wie würdest du das
einschätzen wie schwierig ist das für
diese Partei und im zweiten Schritt für
die generelle ampelregierung
ja ich würde noch ein allerersten
Schritt gehen nämlich oder gerne tun wie
schwierig ist das für Robert Habeck
Robert Habeck war ja zusammen mit
Annalena berborg in den vergangenen
Monaten eine der Lichtgestalten
innerhalb dieser ampelregierung man hat
die Beliebtheitswerte gesehen und die
ersten Debatten kamen auf war es falsch
war es ein großer Fehler für diese
Bundesrepublik das nicht Anna-Lena
baerbock Kanzlerin geworden ist war es
sogar falsch sie damals zur Kandidatin
zu machen und nicht Robert Habeck
und Robert Habeck ist sehr hart
aufgeschlagen in den letzten Wochen
Stichwort
gaspreisumlage gasumlage da hat sich
gezeigt dass da Fehler gemacht wurden in
seinem Ministerium das heißt für ihn ist
es jetzt auch wichtig sich da
einigermaßen wieder rauszuziehen denn
Politik ist ja immer erst das Land und
dann die Parteipolitik ist immer auch
ein ego-spiel es geht auch immer um das
eigene vorkommen dass das erste das
zweite ist genau die Grünen die Grünen
haben die Jugendorganisation die sollte
es anders sein das geht jeder Partei so
im Nacken die Grüne Jugend die da
relativ viel Druck macht ich glaube es
ist innerhalb des grünen Partei
Establishments relativ klar dass man so
jetzt verfahren muss man hat ja in den
vergangenen Monaten Waffenlieferungen in
die Ukraine vorangetrieben da waren die
Grünen auch teilweise sehr viel
offensiver als zum Beispiel der
spd-bundeskanzler Scholz und auch Teile
seiner Partei Teile auch der SPD
Position im Bundestag das heißt
der Gang in die Realpolitik bzw das sehr
pragmatische handeln das ist den Grünen
jetzt nicht heute auf die Füße gefallen
dass sie dazu gezwungen werden sondern
das ist im Zuge dieser Krise die sich
aus dem Krieg des Überfalls des der
Russen Russlands auf die Ukraine ergeben
haben das ist ein roter Faden der sich
dadurch zieht und jetzt den dritten
Schritt die Ampel genau man hat gestern
ein großes ein sehr großes Paket hier in
Berlin präsentiert
der Grünen Koffer sitzende nuripur hat
an einer Stelle gesagt es seien
zeitweilig sehr angespannte Gespräche
gewesen man war aber sehr darauf aus
sich als geeint zu präsentieren Olaf
Scholz hat gestern mehrfach gesagt wie
kollegial mal miteinander gearbeitet hat
wie partnerschaftlich so und nun gibt
heute ungefähr drei Stunden glaube ich
vor der pressek von Robert Habeck deren
Termin da schon fest stand
Christian Lindner der FDP-Chef und
Bundesfinanzminister der Süddeutschen
Zeitung ein Interview und sagt uns ist
es als FDP egal wie dieser Stresstest
ausfällt wir wollen dass alle drei
atombeiler am Netz bleiben das zeigt
eine Menge also entweder geht es
Christian Lindner da also gehen wir mal
davon aus Christian Lindner wusste schon
man arbeitet ja partnerschaftlich und
kollegial zusammen in dieser Koalition
wie dieser Stresstest ausfällt dass also
Robert Habeck heute Abend verkündet wir
gehen mit zwei nicht mit allen drei
Meilern die im Gespräch sind in einem
Notreserve dann wird Christian Lindner
sich mit seiner Aussage gegenüber der
Süddeutschen Zeitung positioniert haben
auch mit Blick auf die Wahl in
Niedersachsen eventuell das heißt also
in Opposition gehen zum
Koalitionspartner oder aber er wusste es
noch nicht und hat versucht Robert
Habeck dadurch noch mal Druck zu machen
ganz klar ist so sieht es nicht aus wenn
man Solar Koalition an einem Strang
zieht deswegen ist da jetzt der Ärger
programmiert einmal deswegen weil jetzt
Robert Habeck ganz offensichtlich etwas
anderes will als die FDP aber auch wegen
des kommunikationsstils von Christian
Lindner ich glaube nicht dass der
spurlos an dieser Koalition vorbei gehen
wird
sagt Nicole Diekmann sie beobachtet die
politische Lage für uns im
Hauptstadtstudio vielen Dank für deine
Zeit und deine Einschätzung hier bei uns
bei ZDF heute live
sehr gerne
nicole hat das gerade schon angesprochen
es birgt eine Menge Konfliktpotenzial
selbst am heutigen Tag wo so eine
dilemma-entscheidung für Robert Habeck
verkündet wird Uneinigkeit in der
Strategie in der Kommunikation und der
ohnehin eine
emotionsgeladene hitzige Debatte
Atomkraft ja oder nein wir sprechen
darüber jetzt weiter mit Karin pittel
sie ist am ifozentrum für Energie Klima
und Ressourcen und jetzt bei uns bei ZDF
heute live schönen guten Abend vielen
Dank für Ihre Zeit
guten Abend sie haben auch die
Pressekonferenz gemeinsam mit uns
verfolgt jetzt ist eben die Entscheidung
gekommen die werden die Atomkraftwerke
zwei der drei im Süden Deutschlands
werden in ein sogenannten steckbetrieb
versetzt und dann eben in ein
reservezzustand aus ihrer Sicht was
bringt diese Entscheidung
die Entscheidung bringt schon dass
zumindest ja erstmal das Gefühl da ist
dass man in Süddeutschland nicht ganz so
unter Druck steht wenn tatsächlich die
Erdgasmenge die für den Stromsektor zur
Verfügung stehen noch weil geringer
werden sollten allerdings bleiben auch
viele Fragen offen also wie dieser
streckbetrieb nachher bzw wie diese
Reserve Situation nachher wirklich
aussehen soll ich glaube das ist noch
nicht völlig klar Atomkraftwerke sind
typischerweise Grundlast das heißt sie
laufen typischerweise durch soll das
jetzt heißen dass wir quasi die
ertrunkenkraftwerke hoch und
runterfahren je nach Bedarf oder ist es
wirklich so gedacht dass wenn im
Dezember absehbar ist das tatsächlich
Erdgas sehr knapp sein wird dass die
Situation in Frankreich besser geworden
ist dass sie dann tatsächlich weiter
durchlaufen das ist aus meiner Sicht
noch nicht wirklich entschieden oder
klar herausgekommen
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung Frau
Kapitel bis hierher wir sehen auch
gerade um welche drei
Atomkraftwerke es geht oder ging in der
ganzen Zeit wir hatten gerade ganz kurz
auch ein paar Tonaussetzer bei ihnen
aber das war doch noch verständlich
deswegen ich habe nichts anderes gehört
können wir auch an der Stelle
weitermachen Frau pittel es ist aber
auch ein weiterer Aspekt über den wir
sprechen müssen und zwar der Verbraucher
Aspekt also diese Entscheidung wird
jetzt getätigt sie sagen es sind viele
offene Fragen aber auch noch offen und
eine Frage die stellen sich viele was
spüren wir davon im Portemonnaie kann
man das schon abschätzen ob diese
Entscheidung jetzt die ja noch sozusagen
beschlossen werden muss final in der
Bundesregierung aber kann man da
abschätzen ob wir Verbraucher das im
Portemonnaie spüren werden dass sich das
entlastet
also rein die Entscheidung ob die beiden
Atomkraftwerke in der Reserve bleiben
oder ob sie weiterlaufen wird für den
Strompreis erstmal nicht weiter nicht zu
viel ausmachen wir haben auch
verschiedene Szenarien mal
durchgerechnet
ganz ohne Erdgas soweit dies möglich ist
also manche
erdgas-bereich müssen wir weiterlaufen
oder eben wenn Erdgas nicht so sehr
eingeschränkt ist und selbst im
extremsten Szenario wird es die
Strompreise nicht substanziell senken
wir haben trotzdem immer noch Erdgas als
quasi das Kraftwerk was als letztes
zugeschaltet wird und was dann den Preis
auf dem Strommarkt setzt das heißt eine
größere rein finanzielle Entlastung
würde ich dadurch nicht erwarten aber
was
natürlich auch gesagt wurde ist dass die
Netzstabilität in der Sicherheit dadurch
durch ausgesteigert werden kann und da
ist natürlich jetzt auch die Diskussion
abzusehen sollten alle drei Kraftwerke
tatsächlich weiterlaufen oder nur die
beiden die Experten hatten ja darauf
hingewiesen dass alle drei Kraftwerke
durchaus ein substanziellen Beitrag
leisten können
passend dazu kommt auch eine Frage rein
von XY PS auf Youtube die geht so ein
bisschen in die Richtung die sie auch
gerade schon thematisiert haben das
erste Daten auch eigentlich zeigen
würden das ist zumindest die Frage eine
Vervielfachung der Energiepreise sollten
dann nicht und das jetzt die Frage des
Users alle Energiequellen genutzt werden
um die Gesellschaft am Ende auch vor
Armut zu schützen
grundsätzlich ist es natürlich richtig
aber die Strommärkte funktionieren eben
so dass quasi der Strompreis order ist
ja ein Begriff den jetzt fast jeder
kennt und früher keiner kannte das
sozusagen das letzte Kraftwerk was an
den Markt geht den Strompreis bestimmt
und wenn das ein Gaskraftwerk ist dann
wird eben dieser diese zusätzlichen
Atomkraftwerke nur relativ wenig
ausmachen was man auch nicht vergessen
darf ist das tatsächlich Erdgas oder
erneuerbare Energien einfach sehr gut
zusammen gehen das heißt also Erdgas
Kraftwerke reagieren viel flexibler als
Atomkraftwerke auf Schwankungen in
erneuerbaren Energien und
dementsprechend ist eben sind jetzt
quasi Atomkraftwerke und Gaskraftwerke
nicht automatisch gegeneinander
substituierbar wenn man so will sondern
es sind verschiedene Bedarfe die auf dem
Strommarkt damit gedeckt werden und
dementsprechend ist es eben nicht so
dass wenn man Atomkraftwerk hochfährt
dementsprechend in gleicher Menge auch
dann tatsächlich weniger Gas braucht
ich schaue immer wieder auch hier in
unsere Community in die Stimmung die ist
gespalten die sagen yo Atomkraft das ist
sicher dass es sauber die anderen sagen
jetzt dieser streckbetrieb und dieses
ganze Drumherum das bringt uns
eigentlich nichts warum gehen wir nicht
einfach wie geplant raus und ein Aspekt
der dabei auch eine wichtige Rolle
spielt das ist der klimaaspekt gestern
wurde ja schon das Entlastungspaket
sozusagen verkündet und auch da ein
Zeichen dass der CO2-Preis erstmal für
dieses Jahr nicht angehoben wird das ist
sozusagen die Erkenntnis daraus und
jetzt heute sprechen wir auch darüber
dass wir ja möglicherweise ein
Reservebetrieb oder einen Reservebetrieb
von Atomkraftwerken haben riskieren wir
da gerade unsere klimapolitischen Ziele
befüllen Sie das einschätzen oder ist
die Situation gerade einfach so enorm
dass man das machen muss
also zum einen ist die Situation
momentan so enorm leider aber
gleichzeitig ist es natürlich auch so
und das wird ja auch immer wieder betont
dass die Stromerzeugung Teil des
europäischen Emissionshandels ist also
der europäischen CO2 Bepreisung und da
wird aktuell zumindest bisher noch
nichts ausgesetzt und die Preise sind
eben auch da und über den
Emissionshandel sind insgesamt die
Mengen die man imitieren darf pro Jahr
auch beschränkt das heißt selbst wenn
ich jetzt substituiere wenn ich von
Kohle von Erdgas auf Kohle übergehe darf
ich dadurch nicht mehr in ganz Europa
imitieren insofern hält sich der
Klimaeffekt tatsächlich in Grenzen auch
wenn es erstmal vielleicht wenig
plausibel erscheint die Entscheidung
gestern
beziehungsweise
die Entscheidung muss man jetzt erstmal
schauen ob es tatsächlich so kommt den
deutschen CO2-Preis nicht weiter zu
erhöhen das betrifft die Stromerzeugung
nicht das betrifft zum Beispiel die
erdgasnutzung für die Wärme zu Hause das
betrifft den Verkehr also wenn sich die
und Diesel und da muss man ehrlich sagen
dass ich halt als verhöhst problematisch
es geht hier um 5 Euro die der Preis zum
nächsten Jahr ansteigen sollte das sind
vielleicht 1,5 Cent pro Liter Benzin
da kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen
dass es eher quasi jetzt ein
Signalwirkung ausübt wir gehen notwendig
also im Notfall einen Schritt zurück
beim Klimaschutz
aber eigentlich für die Preise für die
Konsumenten nicht viel ausmacht also
insofern höchst problematisch man die
komplett falsche Botschafter sendet
eine weitere Frage die uns erreicht das
geht auch in in das Thema Stichwort
Alternativen eine Frage von Konstantin
über Mail er fragt wie wird denn der
Ausbau von Biogas eigentlich gerade
gefördert laut Studien schreibt er aus
dem Jahr 2017 hat Deutschland eigentlich
ein Potenzial von 265 TWh das entspricht
mehr als 25% des jährlichen Bedarfs so
anstatt über Kernkraft sagt er sollte
man mehr über das enorme Potenzial von
Biogas sprechen wie ist da ihre
Einschätzung und man spricht ja durchaus
über beides also biogas ist ja durchaus
auch in der Diskussion hier muss man
natürlich mal aufpassen wie man dieses
Biogas nachher auch produziert und
woraus man es produziert wir wissen alle
dass es bei Monokulturen auch zu
Problemen kommt hier muss im Prinzip
umgestellt werden tatsächlich auf die
Nutzung von Abfallstoffen also von
Reststoffen im Bereich der
Landwirtschaft zum Beispiel und dann
kann man auch wesentlich mehr Biogas
nutzen die reine Erzeugung über quasi
landwirtschaftliche Flächen ist in Bezug
auf Biodiversität geht im Bezug auf die
Grund auch auf Grundwasserverschmutzung
sehr problematisch und insofern muss man
hier vorsichtig sein auch wovon man
genau spricht
Frau Pickel vielleicht zum Abschluss
noch mal eine generelle Zusammenfassung
oder vielleicht auch einen Ausblick aus
ihrer Einschätzung als Expertin es ist
eine enorme emotionsgeladene Debatte die
ja über Jahrzehnte schon geht die jetzt
natürlich dieses Jahr auch noch mal ganz
viele Irrungen und Wendungen erlebt hat
auch über die vergangenen Dekaden und
auch jetzt zeigt sich ja es ist immer
noch sehr komplex was glauben sie kann
man das überhaupt einschätzen wie wird
diese Debatte wie werden diese Prozesse
in den nächsten bleiben wir vielleicht
erstmal bei den Wochen und Monaten
weitergehen oder darüber hinaus
wenn ich das wüsste also ich glaube
schon dass dieser Stresstest dazu führen
wird das zumindest zwei da dieser AKWs
in den schreckbetrieb gehen werden drei
halte ich im Moment nach der
Pressekonferenz auch eher für weniger
wahrscheinlich aber ich bin nicht sicher
ob tatsächlich die Atomkraft Debatte
damit komplett ausgestanden sein wird
denn auch das nächste Jahr wird nicht
einfach werden auch hier werden wir
potenzielle Knappheiten haben wir werden
das Problem haben immer mehr im
Wärmebereich als im Strombereich das
darf man nicht vergessen das
möglicherweise Erdgas sehr sehr knapp
sein wird und insofern kann ich mir sehr
gut vorstellen dass die Diskussion ob
man nicht doch noch mal neue
Brennelemente tatsächlich auch anschafft
und diese AKWs noch länger laufen lässt
im nächsten Jahr bzw ein paar Monaten
wieder hochkommen man hat sich ja jetzt
in der gewissen Weise natürlich dann
auch damit Zeit gekauft dass man diese
Entscheidung auch noch später treffen
kann weil die AKWs eben erst mal in
Betriebsbereitschaft bleiben
also halten wir fest wir werden über
dieses Thema offenbar noch weiter
diskutieren und weiter sprechen vielen
Dank Karin Titel vom ifozentrum für
energieklima und Ressourcen hier bei uns
für ihre Einschätzungen
ich danke natürlich auch euch wieder
fürs zuschauen ihr habt das jetzt auch
mitbekommen wir haben die Entscheidung
dass ja zwei der drei noch vorhandenen
Atomkraftwerke weiter betrieben werden
so in einem sogenannten streckbetrieb
und dann auch in eine reservezustand
versetzt werden ich sehe jetzt bei uns
einen weiteren Gesprächspartner bei uns
im Stream und das ist Uwe Stoll mit dem
wir natürlich noch mal über die
Sicherheitsaspekte rund um die
Kernkraftwerke sprechen wollen schönen
guten Abend Herr Stoll schön dass sie
auch noch mal Zeit gefunden haben für
uns guten Abend
Herr Stoll auch sie haben die
Pressekonferenz verfolgt auch sie wissen
um die Entscheidung wichtigste Frage die
sich natürlich auch viele hier bei uns
im Stream stellen wie sicher sind denn
aber unsere Atomkraftwerke
naja unsere Atomkraftwerke sind oftmals
sicher sonst dürften sie gar nicht
betrieben werden wenn einer
Atomkraftwerk nach hat umgesetzt habe
ich nur betreiben wenn die ausreichende
schadensversorgung gegeben ist und das
ist in unserer Atomkraftwerken gegeben
jetzt ist es aber so dass in den
vergangenen Jahren oder bei
Atomkraftwerken auch das europäische
Atomkraft oder Atomrecht vorsieht das
Atomkraftwerke alle zehn Jahre eine
sogenannte ich muss mal kurz hier gucken
damit ich dann nichts Falsches sage
periodische Sicherheitsprüfung
durchlaufen so und korrigieren Sie mich
wenn ich da falsch liege aber die
letzten bei den AKW in Deutschland die
wurden 2009 gemacht weil ja eigentlich
auch der Plan war die Dinger Ende des
Jahres komplett vom Netz zu nehmen so
muss diese Prüfung nicht aber erst
erfolgen damit man das jetzt so machen
kann
also genau heißt es bei jüdische
Sicherheitsüberprüfung und der
Gesetzgeber hat Termine festgelegt mit
2009 hat aber auch ins Gesetz
reingeschrieben dass ich drei Jahre vor
einer Abschaltung eine solche Prüfung
nicht mehr durchführen muss es war also
eine Entscheidung des Gesetzgebers zu
sagen wann brauche ich so eine Prüfung
und wie häufig muss ich sie machen und
demzufolge muss auch wieder der
Gesetzgeber entscheiden wie gehe ich
jetzt damit um wenn ich so eine kalt
Reserve und weiter Betrieb machen
muss trotzdem wie würden sie es
einschätzen wenn jetzt die Entscheidung
getätigt wird so eine
Sicherheitsüberprüfung das wissen wir
auch die kann Monate dauern die kann
Jahre dauern geht das jetzt so ADOX so
schnell was ist da ihre Einschätzung
wenn man kann die wesentlichen Punkte
einer Sicherheitsüberprüfung relativ
schnell machen eine komplette
Sicherheitsüberprüfung dauert schon 12
Monate und die ist ja dann auch durch
die Gutachter zu prüfen also das ganze
dauert schon eine gewisse Zeit ob das
eine Voraussetzung ist für ein
Weiterbetrieb oder nicht muss wie gesagt
der Gesetzgeber entscheiden
wir haben jetzt auch viel über die
Situation gehört Robert Habeck hat das
auch angesprochen es ist einfach auch
eine schwierige gesamteuropäische
Situation jetzt haben wir gerade in
Frankreich die aktuelle Lage das rund
die Hälfte der Atomkraftwerke aktuell
stillgelegt aufgrund von Mängel aufgrund
von niedrigwasserständen ich meine das
Thema niedrigwasserstände rein das haben
wir auch droht uns da eventuell auch ein
Szenario wie in Frankreich dass man sagt
man kann die Atomkraftwerke am Ende doch
nicht so richtig in Betrieb halten
eine Besonderheit für die
dreiklanglaufwagen in Deutschland sind
dass sie mit Kühlturm gekühlt werden und
bei den Kühlschrank habe ich sehr viel
weniger Anforderungen an das Wasser also
ich habe vom sowohl was die Temperaturen
des Kühlwassers angeht als auch von
Mengen Kühlwasser sehr viel geringere
Mengen als wenn ich Anlagen habe die
keine Kühltürme haben und nur mit Fluss
was gekühlt werden also insofern wäre
die Sache in Deutschland eine andere
Herr stolz ist auch immer wieder die
Rede vom sogenannten streckbetrieb das
ist auch eine Frage die hier im
Community in der Community immer wieder
aufkommt wie
läuft denn sowas dann ab also was wir
verstanden haben es geht um alte
Brennstäbe aber wie geht das denn genau
weiter vielleicht können Sie uns das
noch mal erklären ich versuche es mal
einfach zu erklären wenn ein Reaktor
beladen wird dann hat er eigentlich sehr
viel mehr Uran als er für die 100%
Leistung braucht weil er wird ja dann
noch möglicherweise ein ganzes Jahr
betrieben so und da ich mehr Uran habe
muss ich die dann auch bei der Spaltung
entschieden und zu viel Neutronen wieder
wegfahren dafür nutzt man bohrsäure so
im Laufe des Zyklus ist werden dann die
Urankerne gespalten und das kompensiert
man damit indem man die Borsäure immer
weiter reduziert
und irgendwann ist die Borsäure dann auf
Null runter das heißt der Reaktor kann
eigentlich nicht mehr mit 100% Leistung
betrieben werden und jetzt gibt es einen
einen Trick dabei einen physikalischen
Trick dass ich ja für die Spaltung
sogenannte langsamer Neutronen brauche
das Wasser also im Werkzeug dient auch
dazu die Neutronen abzubremsen wenn ich
jetzt die Temperatur des Wassers etwas
absenke dann wird die Dichte höher und
ich bremse nur darum besser ab und das
ist das was man streckbetrieb nimmt
eigentlich sind die brillente
aufgebraucht sie sind nicht in der Lage
100% Leistung zu liefern indem ich jetzt
aber die Temperatur des Kühlmittels
langsam absinke kann ich noch den Werk
der kritisch halten das heißt im
streckbetrieb nutze ich die brennende
die drin sind produziere aber jeden Tag
so ungefähr ein halbes Prozent weniger
Leistung und das was man diskutiert in
Isa zum Beispiel hatte hat man ja
abgeschätzt ich könnte ungefähr drei
Monate so lange Betrieb machen die
Leistung wurde dann auf ca 60% abfallen
und
ich bräuchte keine neuen brillelemente
sondern würde den Betrieb mit den Brille
mit drin sind weiterführen
vielen Dank dass Sie das noch mal so
ausführlich erklärt haben wir haben
jetzt ja auch die aktuelle Situation
dass die Atomkraftwerke bis April in
Reserve bleiben aber das hat Robert
Habeck auch gesagt am generellen
Atomausstieg daran wird nicht gerüttelt
sie kennen sich jetzt 35 Jahre lang im
Atom Metier aus sie sind technisch
wissenschaftlicher Geschäftsführer auch
der Gesellschaft für Anlagen und
Reaktorsicherheit bleiben wir mal bei
diesem Zeit Aspekt jetzt wird gesagt bis
Ende April erstmal will man sich dieser
Option nicht entledigen ist das
schaffbar sie haben gesagt technisch
oder von der Sicherheit ja aber ist das
auch technisch machbar und wenn ja wie
lange ich habe da schon ein paar
Schwierigkeiten eigentlich mit das
einzuschätzen was bedeutet denn der
Reservebetrieb geht man davon aus dass
man die die Kraftwerke am 31.12 wie
geplant abschaltet und dann zwei Wochen
später sagt oh wir haben jetzt
festgestellt wir brauchen auch wieder
und will sie wieder anfangen das ist
nämlich dann technisch sehr sehr
schwierig und damit habe ich aktuell ein
bisschen so ein Problem inwieweit
denn wirklich festhalten kann oder
sicherstellen kann dass das
Kernkraftwerk dann auch in der Lage ist
wieder anzufahren ich bringe mal ein
ganz plausibles Beispiel ich hatte ja
erwähnt alle diese drei Kernkraftwerke
voll werden im Betrieb durch kühlturme
gekühlt wenn ich mir vorstelle ich habe
kalten Winter mit -20 Grad dann friert
das Wasser im Kühlturm ein und so kann
ich mein Kraftwerk nicht anfahren also
ich habe ein bisschen Problem mir
vorzustellen wie das funktionieren soll
mit dieser Reserve die man dann auch
vorschreiben will und sich dann sehr
spät entscheiden will alles im
Kernkraftwerk wird sehr lange vorgeplant
ich plane also aktuell die Stellung der
Kraftwerke was plane ich denn jetzt
plane ich eigentlich ein weiter Betrieb
ich muss mein Personalplan ich muss
meine Prüfung planen alles das ist
eigentlich im Moment unsicher
und deswegen ist es mir für mich relativ
schwierig dich dieses Thema Reserve bis
zum April technisch vorzustellen okay
was wäre da ihr alternativer Vorschlag
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe aus ihrer
Erfahrung höre ich dann dadurch aus
Kritik und auch ja eher ein großes
Fragezeichen raus
haben ein paar Fragezeichen hinter
wirklich wie man sich das vorstellt und
frage mich dann auch warum man nicht
gleich sagt okay wir wir gehen mit den
Anlagen in streckbetrieb rein betreiben
Sie bis der streckbetrieb nicht mehr
geht und dann hat sich das erledigt aber
ich habe wirklich Schwierigkeiten mir
dieses Thema mit der mit der in Reserve
oder eine Entscheidung oft Mitte
Dezember mir das wirklich vorzustellen
weil das ist planungstechnisch natürlich
nicht also aus meiner Sicht nur sehr
schwer leistbar und dann mache ich dann
auch ein paar Sicherheitsfragen wirklich
dahinter ob das dann alles richtig
geplant ist
und was wäre da die mögliche Alternative
aus ihrer Erfahrung nach
entweder sag ich jetzt gar nicht wir
bleiben beim Termin und diskutieren
nicht über eine Reserve oder aber ich
sage okay wir sagen heute wir machen den
schreckbetrieb das ist die Alternative
aber dieses Thema mit der Reserve halten
das halt die für ja äußerst schwierig in
der technischen Umsetzung was sagen
vielleicht haben sie da Kontakt die
Betreiber zur aktuellen Situation
habe ich keinen direkten Kontakt aber
ich gehe davon aus die werden das auch
analysieren inwieweit das wir sie
möglich ist
ob das technisch überhaupt realisierbar
ist weil aktuell wie gesagt planen Sie
entsprechend Atomgesetz erstmal den den
die stilligung am 31.12 dann dann plant
man normalerweise das Entladen des
Reaktorkerns da gibt es
fremdfirmenführer dann dann gehen die
Planung weiter man denkt an die
Kontamination in diese Planung laufen so
und wenn ich jetzt mir vorstelle das
muss ich jetzt alles auf Eis legen dann
ist das ein ein ziemlicher Aufwand und
weiß nicht ob ich mir dann vielleicht
Strom produziere oder sowas allerdings
wie gesagt aus meiner Sicht darf das
sehr viel Überprüfung inwieweit dann ein
sicherer Betrieb wirklich noch
gewährleistet ist wenn ich solche
Entscheidungen offenhalte bis bis
Dezember wieder Arbeit gesagt direkt
dazu haben wir auch noch eine user-frage
jetzt direkt reinbekommen auch noch mal
von IX Yps er schreibt uns in den
Kommentaren etc heute Frage stellt denn
dann der Reservebetrieb ein größeres
Risiko gegenüber dem streckbetrieb da
also der Reservebetrieb mit
abgeschalteten Anlage würde ich sagen
ist kein größeres Risiko nur wenn ich
dann plötzlich hinkomme und sage ich
will mein Kraftwerk jetzt wieder
anfahren dann würde ich sagen
würde ich da schon ein paar
sagt Uwe Stoll hier bei uns bei ZDF
heute live zum Thema Reaktor Sicherheit
zum Thema Sicherheit der Atomkraftwerke
in Deutschland vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
und für ihre Einschätzungen
gutes Stichwort ich danke euch natürlich
auch fürs zuschauen bei diesem wirklich
sehr komplexen Thema wir hoffen dass wir
ein paar eurer Fragen ein paar offene
Punkte klären konnten zumindest
thematisieren konnten denn wir haben das
auch schon heute gesehen wir haben das
erkannt wir haben es mit Nicole Diekmann
besprochen die die Zerrissenheit in der
ampelregierung dargestellt hat die die
Zerrissenheit von Robert Habeck und die
Schwierigkeit der Kommunikation dieser
Entscheidung dargestellt hat und eben
auch die Frage okay wir haben eigentlich
beschlossen den Atomausstieg dieses Jahr
zu machen jetzt gerade wegen der
aktuellen Lage müssen wir das neu
bewerten und gehen in ein Reservebetrieb
bis April die Sache ist nicht geklärt
sie ist weiter offen und wir werden da
sicher noch weiter hier bei ZDF heute
live drüber sprechen vielen Dank für
heute und bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss